and we thank you for joining us on 8
news now at 11 i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez we're now less than 24
hours from the start of that pause for
classes within ccsd the district making
the decision because of such a high
number of cobit cases and subsequent
staffing shortages kids will have a five
day weekend which has so many parents
scrabbling to find a game plan sasha
loftus spoke with a mom tonight who says
this will not be easy on her family yes
denise and brian the parent i spoke with
tonight says this is a strain on she and
her kids she said they can make it work
for a few days but doesn't want to see
this kind of thing happen again
well
here we go again ty bates is a mother of
four and juggling schedules is anything
but easy it's going to be quite
difficult with them being at home she
says tuesday's announcement of ccsd's
five-day pause due to covet 19 related
staff shortages was the last thing her
family wanted to hear they're like no
they're not about to go on another
five-day pause because the last time
they did that it would went from
two-week pause all the way to a year and
a half this comes four months after the
district announced an allotment of
federal relief funds with 217 million
going to coronavirus mitigation and 11
million dedicated to filling around 700
teacher vacancies we've had parents
scrambling at the last minute sarah cook
who owns local care company nannies and
grannies says her phone is ringing off
the hook as many request babysitters
nannies or even virtual caretakers to
keep their kids busy trying to figure
out what they're going to do and what
the game plan will be bates says she'll
do everything she can to cross this
hurdle i hope they understand that cove
is not going anywhere but hopes to see a
different game plan so her kids can
safely stay in the classroom
the district has canceled classes from
january 14 this friday through tuesday
january 18th with kids set to return to
in-person learning that wednesday both
ccsd and governor steve sisilak say they
want to avoid falling back to remote
learning back to you guys